un ministre qui passe son temps sur les
plateaux télévisés plus tôt que de nous
écrire des directives claires et
précises sur les droits de chacun la
première chose là on a eu un décret qui
est sorti seulement hier concernant les
personnels vulnérables le sens de ce
rassemblement c'est déjà pour dénoncer
les fermetures de classes qui lie
actuellement sur la seine-et-marne le
manque de moyens que nous avons depuis
tant d'années c'est à dire qu'on a un
plan de rattrapage qui est inexistant et
les paranos mort les parents attendent
un vrai plan de rattrapage cette fois ci
c'est aussi pour la rentrée avec
justement le protocole sanitaire qui est
allégé les parents de ces démarches se
demander en cas de fermeture
effectivement nous a dit que c'était la
rs et on sait très bien comment le joint
certaines écoles ou complètement fermé
comment ça va se passer pour les parents
qui ont repris le travail et qu'on fait
trop le choix
donc qui va garder les enfants si je
peux dire quelque chose vraiment nul
vraiment et en comparaison justement
avec l'italie et l'italie ce n'est pas
un gouvernement révolutionnaire ça c'est
un gouvernement en coalition avec les 5
étoiles et le parti démocrate
c'est pas un gouvernement
révolutionnaire c'est quand même un
gouvernement qui prend la mesure de ce
qu'a voulu dire
cette épidémie le lycée jacques amyot
hamelin la densité d'élèves par classe
et entre 27 et 30
et là on fait une rentrée entre 27 et 30
élèves par